thomas bonjour alors je ne le dirais de
voir philippe prend la porte cet après
midi devant le sénat de quoi sera-t-il
question exactement est bien le premier
ministre est attendu d'ici 30 minutes
environ pour présenter devant les
sénateurs les contours de ce plan de
déconfinement est également entériné la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pour une période de deux mois
supplémentaires jusqu'au 24 juillet
prochain c'est la deuxième prise de
parole d'edouard philippe en l'espace
d'une semaine après celle de mardi
dernier devant l'assemblée nationale
plusieurs mesures vont être au coeur des
discussions avec park
à commencer par les brigades sanitaire
la mise en place de ces brigades
sanitaire qui seront chargés de récolter
des données sur les malades et sur leur
entourage
autre mesure qui fait débat c'est la
mise en quarantaine des arrivants sur le
territoire une mesure annoncée samedi à
l'issue du conseil des ministres et qui
a été corrigé depuis par l'elysée qui
explique que cette mesure ne concernera
finalement pas les personnes qui
arrivent de l'espace schengen et du
royaume uni
parmi les autres mesures qui devraient
être discutées cet après midi il ya
notamment la question des masques la
question des tests et la question très
délicate de la réouverture des écoles à
compter du 11 mai prochain il faut
rappeler que edouard philippe a donc
s'exprimer pendant environ une heure
puis ce seront les différents
représentants des groupes politiques du
sénat qui vont prendre l'art a pas de la
parole on rappelle que la majorité au
sénat est acquise au groupe l'est
républicain dont le président bruno
retailleau a fait savoir qu'il comptait
lancer une commission d' enquête sur la
gestion de la crise par le gouvernement
thomas merci pour toutes ces précisions